a we have now learned that Donald and Melania
Trump received their covid vaccines at the
White House in January, but kept it secret.
I will talk a little bit about why it's believed
that they kept it secret.
But unfortunately, I think there is no way
to deny that Donald and Melania Trump, keeping
their covid vaccinations secret for months
led to some deaths that could have been prevented.
And I'll explain why momentarily.
CNN reporting that Trump and Melania received
the covid-19 vaccine in January.
This is per a Trump adviser talking to CNN.
It wasn't clear which of the vaccines they
received.
It wasn't clear how many doses they received.
And this was something that the question of
this came up and it came up on my stream on
Sunday as we were covering Donald Trump's
CPAC speech.
Donald Trump said everybody should get the
vaccine.
And, of course, his goal in saying that was
a political goal and taking credit for the
vaccine and saying, hey, I got us the vaccine,
everybody should get it.
This immediately raised the question.
As Donald Trump told the audience, the vaccine
is very unpatentable, unusual choice of terms,
but it's Trump, OK?
It raised the question, did Trump get the
vaccine?
We know Joe Biden did.
Trump even mentioned it, saying, my work on
vaccines got Joe a vaccine.
And the question became, did Trump get the
vaccine?
In December, the White House said Trump wasn't
going to be given a vaccine until it was recommended
by the White House medical team and that Trump
was still receiving the benefits of that antibody
treatment he got when he had covid-19 and
that that was that.
We've now learned that Trump accepted the
vaccine while still president at the White
House in January.
No public fanfare, no public announcement.
And now the question is, could lives have
been saved if it had been publicly known that
Trump had been vaccinated?
I believe the answer is yes.
We won't ever know how many and we won't ever
be able to point to who.
But one of the most vaccine hesitant groups
in the country is Republicans, we previously
spoke about how folks without college degrees,
black folks and Republicans are the three
most anti covid vaccine groups in the country
for different reasons.
Republicans have much of their opposition
or lack of interest in the covid vaccine,
based in the constant disinformation that
came from Donald Trump's White House, that
this isn't that serious and that we can get
back to normal without a vaccine and so on
and so forth.
So there's no doubt that there are can we
say thousands?
Could we say tens of thousands of Republicans
who did not get vaccinated?
Had they known Trump had been vaccinated in
January, many of them would have gotten a
vaccine.
And simply statistically speaking, some of
them got covid and died because they didn't
get the vaccine.
And they would have had they known Trump had
gotten it and was saying in January, everybody
should get it instead of waiting until February
28th to say everybody should get it.
We won't know exactly how many.
We won't know exactly who.
But there is no question that this is the
latest action by Donald Trump that caused
some deaths, some deaths that could have been
prevented.
We now have a study which suggests 40 percent
of the covid deaths during the Trump presidency
were due to bad policy.
Of course, we were going to have many deaths.
This ravaged just about every country in the
world, but 40 percent of them were because
of bad management by the federal government
and by state governments as well.
And certainly Trump keeping his vaccine a
secret for months only made that even worse.
We will have more coverage of this on The
David Pakman Show Instagram.
Find us there at The David Pakman Show,